[Music]
kumail I'm gonna start with you
Silicon Valley you're on the show
Silicon Valley which is one of my
favorite shows this season it's
hilarious Oh congratulations you guys
have a bunch of Emmy nominations yeah
yeah thank you it's been it's been
awesome people seem to really like show
[Applause]
Jonah we saw you start the applause no
no no there's some other guy
okay incredible I'm with the guy so
Kumail the yeah the show is hilarious
yeah and you know last time I was here I
was talking about how my mom is never
really impressed by anything so with
this one I was like hey you gotta watch
it's a show on HBO so she watched the
first few and she liked it and then
there's one episode where there's an
image that I was a little concerned
about we hire on the show a graphic
designer to make a logo for the company
you're a bunch of web startup guys yeah
and you try to make a new logo yeah and
so this guy makes a huge garage door
sighs graffiti piece that is me in a
spec a warrior outfit can we just show
the picture so I think right yeah so as
you can see it's me and then you're do
you're doing that to the Statue of
Liberty yep I'm taking liberties with
the Statue of Liberty yeah so I had to
call my mom and be like hey there's
gonna be something you're not gonna love
in this one but so just be ready for it
and then she watched and she called me
and she was like come out we just got to
this country you're penetrating the
Statue of
isn't that the immigrant dream mom to
come here make love to freedom isn't
that why we didn't look like you were
making love you look like you're
enjoying yeah no one's enjoying that
scenario and don't put it up again
alright
you